[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
brand jt des territoires sur nos chaînes
de la tnt locale et régionale et sur tv5
monde
l'actualité cette semaine est inscrit en
région dans les territoires et bien
c'est la rentrée pour les entreprises
pour les écoles pour les universités une
rentrée marquée bien sûr par le respect
des normes sanitaires qu'il faut
absolument respecter
rappelons le alors allons voir
concrètement ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
à l'université de versailles où les
étudiants sont aussi de retour après de
longs mois de confinement est également
d'été bien sûr les cours ont repris
cette semaine comment l'établissement
s'organise en plein contexte épidémique
eh bien regardez ce reportage signé de
nos confrères de tv 78 dans les yvelines
il était un peu déboussolé ce matin
après six mois de cours à la maison
les étudiants de la faculté de droit ont
retrouvé les bancs des amphis oui ça
fait depuis mars népal en cours et leur
revenir en en chine avec une place sur
deux même les amphis moins bondée ça oui
ça fait bizarre même avec les yeux on a
eu du coup une nouvelle un nouveau truc
imposé par la fac et du coup on est en
semaine à semaine b les amphis sont
divisées par deux noms précis spécial
quand même il ya toujours quand même
cette petite pointe d'appréhension de se
dire qu'on est énormément dans cette fac
et que forcément il y aura des quatre
coronavirus mais globalement sinon ça va
en tout le monde almas il ya tout le
temps du gel à disposition c'était la
rentrée aussi pour cette professeur de
droit devant elle deux cents étudiants
au lieu de 400 pour respecter la
distanciation social c'est une nouvelle
organisation à mettre en place et nous
les enseignants nous allons faire ce
qu'on appelle des enseignements hybride
c'est-à-dire qui aura une partie de
cours dans lequel nous accueillerons un
petit groupe en présentiel et puis une
partie de cours à distance et le système
est conçu pour que y ait une forme de
rotation
son cours est désormais filmer pour
permettre aux autres étudiants de suivre
à distance ses équipes et ils ont ces
derniers mois on a équipé ont été assez
peu équipés d'outils numériques soit de
moyens de captation vidéo où l'outil de
web conférences déjà c'est le premier
point est le deuxième point si
l'attention particulière sur les ce
qu'on appelle les étudiants
primo-entrants cette vidéo bacheliers
pour faire en sorte de les accueillir et
de les prioriser pour les accueillir en
présence hier à la bibliothèque
universitaire impossible d'accueillir
tous les étudiants d'habitude la
bibliothèque compte 1100 places assises
dorénavant seulement 500 seront proposés
et les étudiants devront les réserver
finies aussi les travaux en groupe
les salles sont désormais individuelles
et les 10000 livres empruntés à
l'extérieur seront à leur tour mises en
quarantaine pendant trois jours
dans ce grand jt des territoires
direction le nord de la france
maintenant la picardie plus précisément
amiens en 2024 vous le savez sans doute
nous allons tous être obligé de trier à
la source
nos biodéchets les entreprises comme les
particuliers
certains d'ailleurs ont pris de l'avancé
déjà l'association amiénoise les recycle
est collecte à vélo les déchets verts
dans les restaurants et monte des
projets de bacs collectifs à compost
pour les particuliers ou les entreprises
regardez ces explications de nos
confrères de la chaîne wéo la chaîne de
la voix du nord ils font chauffer leurs
mollets pour la revalorisation des
déchets
olivier charles de l'association les
recycler tu pédales dans les rues
amiénoise pour aller récolter les
biodéchets des restaurants pour ensuite
les composter
ce jour-là 45 kg ont été récoltés au
haddock café 45 kg qui ne finiront donc
pas dans la poubelle de l'établissement
et qui seront compostés et donc recyclé
le mois dernier alors qu'on n'a pas fait
un mois complet on était déjà à quatre
cents 400 kg de déchets alimentaires
donc c'est énorme c'est énorme donc
autant que ça serve à quelque chose
les recycler propose ce service de
collecte à vélo depuis début 2000 20 et
travaille aujourd'hui avec une dizaine
de restaurateurs de la ville est presque
deux tonnes de biodéchets ont déjà été
récoltés et ont continué leur vie dans
ces bacs à compost du quartier leboeuf
on est passé à ba2 et plus sûr de
carottes épluchures de pommes de terre
pour ça à assat de la terre en fête de
la terre plein de plein de bonnes choses
un tiers du contenu de nos poubelles est
composée de déchets compostables et pour
les professionnels de la restauration ce
volume monte à la moitié de leurs
poubelles et pour livia cofondatrice de
l'association s'intéresser à leur
revalorisation amène souvent l'envi de
voir plus loin
une fois qu'on a enlevé un tiers de sa
poubelle mais en fait on regarde sa
poubelle 11e en fait qu'est-ce qui reste
dedans
est ce que je peux réduire davantage en
optant pour des options réutilisables
on se mettant à sauter en vrac c'est un
premier pas on va dire vers la réduction
plus globale de ces déchets et en
parallèle de leurs services pour les
professionnels les recycle est veulent
aussi sensibiliser les particuliers aux
bienfaits du compostage
ici rue laisse couvé l'association
installé un composteur collectif et 5
seront bientôt mises en place dans
d'autres quartiers d'amiens pour
répondre à une demande croissante
on a été beaucoup contacté par des
particuliers particulière que c'est
vraiment l'association de répondre à un
vrai besoin
et de lancer des initiatives que les
gens voulaient voir naître depuis
longtemps notre but voilà c'est de
sensibiliser au maximum est d'apprendre
aux gens à faire eux mêmes ou à faire
avec les autres et d'ici 2024 chacun
particuliers comme professionnels devra
trier c'est bio déchets à la source
et pour accompagner le plus grand nombre
dans cette transition les recycler et
organise de nombreux ateliers pour que
composter devienne un geste citoyen et
responsable facile et accessible à tous
voilà septembre c'est aussi lors du
bilan de l'été vous avez été très
nombreux à rester en france tout l'été à
sillonner les routes de notre beau pays
peut-être d'ailleurs en camping car car
ce secteur est en plein boom et le
centre des expositions du mans a
accueilli le salon de la maison et de
l'auto le week-end dernier
l'occasion de constater avec les
professionnels la bonne santé de ce
marché en plein boom le marché des
camping cars donc toutes les
explications avec ce reportage de rltv
sarthe
le camping car un secteur qui ne connaît
pas la crise avec des dizaines de
modèles présentés au salon de l'auto
c'est le produit phare de l'événement
largement plébiscités par les clients
c'était tranquille avec ma femme tous
les deux voyages et voir beaucoup de
petits villages de partir à la semaine
ou partir de trois semaines comme ça à
voir la crise du coronavirus semble
avoir redistribué les cartes sur le type
d'hébergement de séjour recherché par
les sarthois ont envie de changer un
petit peu notre style de vacances
d'avoir des gens peut-être plus en
sécurité
par rapport à ce qui se passe
actuellement et puis de pouvoir avoir
des
des vacances différentes avec les
petits-enfants pouvoir voyager changer
d'endroit régulièrement les
professionnels le confirme depuis le
déconfinement les ventes explosent pour
ce type de véhicule puis mi mai on
n'arrête pas va de nouvelles vacances de
nouvelles de nouveaux projets de vie se
sont
révélé aux gens on va dire on va voir on
va dire le côté un peu plus safe en lire
+ sécurité de nouvelles habitudes de
séjour qui ont même permis aux vendeurs
de camping-cars de combler le trou
économique de la mi mars à la mi mai
tout ce qui était confinement
aujourd'hui pendant les deux mois
d'arrêt on a rattrapé le retard donc les
gens se sont rués sur le camping cars
que c'est un milieu qui est sur quoi une
sécurité et une flexibilité qui rassure
d'après les professionnels tous les
secteurs du caravaning connaissent un
boom des ventes les motor-homes et les
caravanes connaissent aussi un franc
succès chez les acheteurs
direction la loire maintenant regardez
ce reportage très étonnant avec cette
belle histoire celle d'une reconversion
très réussi ce ligérien est âgé de 36
ans il était ostéopathe et il l'est
devenu désormais fabricant de
chaussettes et oui des produits 100 %
made in france
références musicales et pour toutes les
générations anthony vers pillon notre
confrère de tl7 est allé le rencontrer
sur place chez lui rien
la journée non les gangsters moderne sex
machine space cowboy yellow submarine
le crazy in love des california love et
little bird bob marley simple et funky
et un peu plusieurs comprendront le mr
dans ce bar c'est elle la nouvelle
marque tendance issue de la loire
marthe il est né de l'esprit
bouillonnant de ce jeune trentenaire
originaire du rouennais un style qui
rend hommage à la musique et aux
skateurs californien des années soixante
dix l'outil de mode qu'il veut surtout
intergénérationnel je voulais aussi bien
un enfant de trois ans que que les
parents ou voir les grands-parents puce
lemaître et qu'un enfant de trois ans
puisse mettre des chaussettes les mêmes
chaussettes que son père avec des
références à gainsbourg mr gainsbarre et
qui puisse dire à son père c'est qu'ils
mr gainsbourg et des chaussettes qui
sont également 100% made in france
mis à part le coton tout le reste est
fabriquée chez nous de l'assemblage au
packaging pour un prix de vente à 10 8
euros la paire est caractéristique
inédite march il réussi à convoquer les
cinq sens j'ai le toucher parce qu'on
voit que les produits sont comme de
qualité en elles sont toutes molletonné
on est vraiment super bien pour le
concevoir
j'ai louis parce qu'il ya quand même une
référence musicale et j'ai l'odorat
parce que 30 mois je les envoie leçon
tout parfumé avec des huiles
essentielles
donc comme ça quand on ouvre le papier
on a l'odeur mais pour parvenir à ce
résultat en moins d'un an elle est
oubliée a opéré un véritable virage à
360 degrés dans sa carrière
professionnelle moi j'étais ostéopathe
vocaux tôt pendant la presque une
quinzaine d'années on a tendance à aller
un petit peu mine de rien vers un peu
plus de psychologique j'arrive plus à
gérer l'émotionnel de mon boulot donc
c'était c'était plus possible - au
départ je connaissais rien textile c'est
c'est vraiment a ressenti
donc du coup aller vers quelque chose
qu'on ressent tout de suite je trouve
que c'est plus simple quoi
alors on en a beaucoup entendu parler
vous le connaissez il s'agit du loto du
patrimoine qui nous intéresse maintenant
dans ce grand jt des territoires parmi
la nouvelle sélection on retrouve dans
les vosges la maison paysanne de
bulletins une bâtisse du début du xviie
siècle qui menace de s'écrouler
son propriétaire est un très grand
passionné de vieilles pierres il espère
bien là sauvé par le biais du loto de
gros travaux ont déjà commencé et via
vosges est allé à sa rencontre
regardez
dernière ligne droite pour jouer au loto
du patrimoine et participer à la
sauvegarde de la maison paysanne de bus
près de rambervillers c'est ce bâtiment
en péril qui a été sélectionné pour le
département des vosges ou fermes
anciennes qui resté dans son jus qui est
t'il à 2605 c'est pas rien et qui
reflètent de tout sur plan que sa façade
toiture etc
mais ce qu'elle était à l'époque c'est
là c'est vraiment la ferme d'époque
voilà 15 ans que la fondation du
patrimoine s'inquiète pour l'état
général du bâtiment
suite à un accident de la route en 2012
la maison est endommagé et doit être
rasé c'est donc une fierté pour la
commune que le nouveau propriétaire
accepte le défi et tente de la restaurer
c'est parfait pour nous d'avoir une
personne comme ça on en parlera
longtemps dans les livres d'histoire de
but je pense que ce rang photos et sera
notée dessus c'est certain amoureux des
vieilles pierres jeu rumba landes en est
pas à son coup d'essai c'est la
troisième maison qu'ils restaurent celle
ci c'est son coup de foudre de jeunesse
aujourd'hui il y consacre tout son temps
libre
la liste des travaux est impressionnante
c'est une toiture avec une couverture
provisoire parce que j'avais pas les
moyens ni le temps puisque la toiture la
couverture pardon définitif sera une
couverture en tuiles rondes ce qu'on
appelle ici la tige de bottes la
fondation du patrimoine le département
la région ont participé à financer les
premiers travaux jérôme par l'urgence
éviter que le bâtiment ne s'effondre
début xviie on devine encore un style
renaissance la mode dans la campagne
lorraine a évolué moins vite qu'en ville
les deux tiers du bâtiment servait à
l'exploitation agricole attenant un
logement modeste et un plus riches il
avait une belle pièce de réception en
fils imaginer que le mur là n'existait
pas donc il va être supprimé et après
hop à ce qu'il en reste de la france
mais avant de s'atteler à l'aménagement
intérieur il faut consolider les
ouvertures et lutter contre un
affaissement des fondations en train
d'enlever
les dernières pierres anciennes qui sont
des très dégradé alors c'est une maison
qui à 415 enquête est construite avec
ses amours doges on appelle ça un rodage
de maçonnerie en pierre et en terre donc
en fait ça se tient c'est un ensemble ça
ne certaine souplesse avec l'humidité
elle penche elle tord et elle elle prête
à s'écrouler mais le tient encore les
pierres trop allumé sont refaites à
l'identique la pause interviendra de 10h
à 12h ce week-end pour les journées du
patrimoine le propriétaire espère
beaucoup en la mission berne
il connaîtra la somme qui lui est alloué
fin novembre à titre comparatif l'an
dernier le chalet tivoli à plombières
les bains avait obtenu 180 mille euros
bonjour jean jacques farré vous êtes
l'invité du grand jt des territoires
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef directeur de la
publication de tous les jours curieux
avec gilles courtinat c'est un magazine
sorti cet été
bizarrement vu la tendance actuelle
c'est un magazine en papier qui est
consacré à votre passion la photo
pourquoi avez vous choisi le papier
alors que tout le monde choisit le
numérique
pourquoi voir 16e papier ce qui nous
intéressait c'était non pas de faire un
magazine mais plutôt une revue la revue
présente cet avantage d'être un petit
format pour lequel on peut écrire de
très bons papiers et nous notre coeur du
dispositif c'était de faire parler des
peu les photographes dé faire parler
longuement avec une belle impression de
montrer de montrer leur image tout
simplement et de les faire parler
voilà pour moins de 10 euros c'est un
magazine très éclectique avec un
sommaire extrêmement variées vous
traitez de la grippe espagnole ça nous
rappellera la crise sanitaire que nous
venons de vivre parle également des
gaulois réfractaires alors vous concluez
qu'au fil des ans est un pays la france
qui ne change pas c'est vrai ça le sujet
sur les gaulois réfractaires qui
s'appelle les français nous publions
deux grands entretiens
qui sont en fait une bourse qui a été
donné par le ministère de la culture à
deux photographes formidable là qui
était éric bouvet et l'autre yann morvan
qui depuis deux ans et demi
sillonne la france à la recherche si
vous voulez 2d des typologies française
et c'est ce qui est très intéressant de
ce travail c'est que le travail d
enquête ce qu'il raconte très bien tous
les deux dans les deux entretiens a été
un véritable travail de journaliste
avant d'arriver à faire les fous les
photos qui sont ces mots pour me double
jean jacques farré vous êtes un
passionné de photos bien sûr vous avez
été très important au service photo de
libération pendant des années on dit que
la photo c'est fini on dit que les
agences de presse ont rendu l'âme que
seuls deux ou trois groupes mondiaux se
partagent maintenant les fonds photo
mondiaux est ce qu'il ya un avenir pour
la photo comment le voyez-vous cet
avenir pour la photo il ya une nouvelle
génération qui arrive avec de nouvelles
armes de nouveaux points de vue qui ne
qui ne cherchent pas à publier sur le
papier qui sont sur les réseaux qui
produisent des choses extrêmement
intéressante
merci à vous serrer de vie et voilà on
ouvre une page sports dans ce grand jt
des territoires surtout quand le sport
se met au caritatif
vous allez le voir c'est le challenge
calvi monaco dont on va parler
maintenant une course au long cours plus
de 22 heures de traversée avec une
princesse comme pilote vous allez le
voir l'équipe serenity a mené par la
princesse charlene l'épousé du prince
albert de monaco a été la première à
franchir la ligne d'arrivée et via télé
pas aisé nos confrères de corse étaient
sur place
regardez
je suis resté ici sur site notamment
avec la princesse qui étaient là donc
pour passer notamment un petit peu de
temps ici en vue du challenge du
crossing sais comment c'est passé
l'entraînement pour le vélo
malheureusement il n'a pas dix mille
façons il faut vraiment faire du vélo
des kilomètres et des kilomètres donc on
va dire un entraînement régulier de vos
dires 4 x 4 5 fois par semaine au plus
haut plus de genre de l'entraînement
quelles sont les spécificités du wat
r'bike faut vraiment avoir on va dire un
rythme constant parce que ces deux
boudins vont dire de type kayak et qui
sont si vous voulez avec une hélice en
plein milieu est vraiment une selle un
guidon vraiment comme un vélo après la
seule chose qui sera un petit peu
différente c'est qu'on est vraiment sur
un élément qui s'est vraiment à part
entière et on va dire que ça change pas
mal de choses parce que c'est pas une
route
donc ça bouge et la météo elle joue un
rôle déterminant s'il ya vraiment il ya
vraiment beaucoup de vent et beaucoup de
vagues
ça rend la chose super difficile ce qu
est la princesse est prête à est super
prête elle est super positive elle est
prête à faire ce gros s'il sait que les
sportifs de haut niveau donc on va dire
qu'ils ont l'habitude des événements un
petit peu comme ça donc sportifs de haut
niveau concentré à max je suis leur
équipe notorious avec le frère la
princesse à garrett et voilà on espère
pouvoir rivaliser avec l'équipe adverse
qui est je pense bien armé pour pour
gagner cette course c'est quand même une
aventure fantastique c'est un exploit
sportif certes mais je vais aussi
chercher un petit peu de convivialité
le fait de le faire en relais voilà ça
ressemble un petit peu à ce que ce que
je vis mon avec le handball donc puis
après c'est pour une noble cause donc je
pense que c'est toujours important de
participer à des événements qui sera
organisé pour récolter des fonds et
aider des bonnes causes
cette traversée comme tout match se
prépare comment vous êtes vous
approprier le watergate
hier matin on a fait un essai j'ai
trouvé l'utilisation très simple c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez stable
et donc du coup la prise en main a été
plutôt rapide
la stratégie c'est de faire des relais
ni cour nylon je pense que nous on va
partir sur des relais d'une heure et
demie environ
et après on fera suivant notre état
physique dans toutes les disciplines
sportives dans tous les grands défis
sportifs
l'aspect mental est le plus important du
trac y en a toujours mais mais quand on
a fait du sport de haut niveau je pense
que le trac quand on arrive à le
transformer en une énergie positive
il faut pas que ce soit quelque chose
qui nous unit ou ou qu'ils nous fassent
entre limay perdre nos moyens a
peut-être que l'état de la mer pour
éventuellement un moment nous
déstabiliser mais voilà le bateau ne
sera pas très très loin on garde tous
analyse sur sur chacun et je pense que
voir avec un peu de bienveillance ça va
bien se passer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les 100 ans de la machine à coudre
ça se fait et ça se fait bien vous allez
le voir dans ce grand jt des territoires
l'association remis patrimoine si tu as
remis sur scène à exposer une partie de
sa collection de 165 machine à coudre
issus de dons ou de prêts des amis du
musée de la bonneterie de 3 nos
confrères de canal 32 nous font
découvrir certaines de ces merveilles
vous allez le voir son bruit
identifiables a traversé le siècle
jusqu'à devenir l'un des objets de
l'année 2020 je pense que c'est l'objet
de l'année 2020 à cause de la pandémie
nous on a fait son temps de machines à
coudre du fait qu'on a voulu commencer
par la plus ancienne de 1872
deux années ont été nécessaires un
bénévole pour préparer cette exposition
recherche fiche photographie
s'intéresser aux machines à coudre
permet d'aborder des histoires
singulières et la grande histoire
il suffit de se laisser surprendre pour
être emporté
nous avions un bénévole claude qui est
tombé amoureux des machines à coudre et
il a apporté un regard nouveau et nous
qui venions du milieu industriel
machines à coude en pense qu'elle va
servir à faire de la confection
effectivement mais c'est aussi des
petits bijoux
vous avez une décoration par
décalcomanie qu'extraordinaire vous avez
également des incrustations en nacre
pour attirer l'oeil l'achat sur la
marque également cette chine a toujours
été mon coup de coeur donc c'est une
petite machine à coups de portables très
simple puisque le mouvement et fait
ainsi pour pouvoir coup double
l'association fête ses 20 ans l'ensemble
de sa collection repose sur des dons
suivre l'évolution de la machine à
coudre permet également de mieux se
rendre compte des évolutions techniques
économiques et sociales durant un siècle
ont tourné les manivelles pour pour cool
ensuite le pédalier l'électrification
vous avez quartier de romilly qui ont
reçu l'électricité les derniers
quartiers en 1950 et sur le pédalier ici
vous avez pont-sur-seine de la machine
régional qui a totalement disparu a
aujourd'hui les machines base sont plus
fabriqués en france principalement
à l'étranger en allemagne est très
souvent vu s'en fait en sous traitance
en chine
mon père était maçon l'été est ailleurs
l'hiver et l'évolution du tailleur chez
un petit peu focaliser à ce moment là
pour
disparaître dans les années 70 ça
revient énormément les enfants sont très
doués de leurs maris sont captivés par
ce qu'ils se rendent compte qu avec un
petit morceau de l'aisne ne serait-ce
qu'un morceau de tissu on est capable de
créer des jolies choses
les visites sur rendez vous peuvent se
dérouler les jeudis après midi samedi et
dimanche
situé à proximité du technicentre de la
sncf l'association ouvrira les portes de
l'espace vivans de la bonneterie
à l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
le 19 et 20 septembre
voilà nous partons en bretagne à présent
dans ce grand jt des territoires car ils
avaient dû cesser toutes ses activités
le 13 mars dernier pour cause de
qu'ovide 19
le cabaret moustache de nouvoitou a
réouvert ses portes récemment
sur scène c'est sont douze artistes qui
propose un nouveau spectacle vous allez
le voir notre confrères de tv rennes qui
ne portent pas de moustache lui assister
à la reprise des représentations
regardez ce reportage
midi pile au cabaret moustache tout
nouveau et tout les premiers spectateurs
rentrent dans la seule pour un déjeuner
spectacle
le premier depuis la crise de l'accord
vise bel retrouver entre amis c'est très
important et c'est très convivial et ça
nous fait beaucoup de bien
pour donner du baume au coeur ici les
règles de distanciation sont identiques
à celles de la restauration
on va ouvrir nos sur un sur une charge
de 140 maximum au lieu de 200 donc on
est juste sur la jauge de notre seuil de
rentabilité donc voilà ses nuits dans la
tête que cette année ce sera une année
blanche on gagnera pas d'argent mais on
va essayer de sauver les meubles et est
au moins de pouvoir rester ouverte
c'est l'objectif ce fut aussi la rentrée
pour les douze artistes intermittents du
spectacle on est tous super vraiment
motivés et puis on attendait que ça quoi
moi pour ma part c'était sport tous les
matins on avait tous hâte que cabaret
réouvre ses portes au plus vite
ça nous a manqué le cabaret moustache
repart sur un rythme de trois spectacles
par semaine et doit d'abord commencer
par rattraper les 700000 euros de perte
de chiffre d'affaires engendré par la
cessation d'activité du printemps été
voilà donc ce grand jt des territoires
nous soulignons aussi les initiatives de
nos confrères selon la presse écrite qui
prennent le temps de regarder ce qui se
passe dans nos territoires dans nos
belles régions françaises
c'est le cas ce mois ci du numéro 2 de
bien à la campagne
un magazine du groupe reward médias qui
nous incite et bien parfois abandonner
les villes
si on le peut pour aller s'installer à
la campagne c'est le cas et bien de ces
témoignages de ce couple qui s'est
installée dans le gère dans ce numéro 2
donc de bien la campagne
et puis également de ce qu'il faut
planter en cette saison dans votre
jardin
ce magazine bien à la campagne donc a
pour vocation est bien de regarder de
quelle manière on peut peut-être vivre
un peu autrement bien à la campagne
nous soulignons cette initiative dans le
grand jt des territoires voilà les plus
je signale les deux éditions locales du
magazine le point cette semaine qui sont
fort bien fait
l'une consacrée à toulouse comme vous le
voyez sur cet écran c'est la une que
vous voyez toulouse avec ce décollage
d'un airbus béluga de l'aéroport de
toulouse blagnac un joli petit airbus
avec une tête de dauphin qui sourit elle
est amusante c'est une avec un sujet
très fort principal l'aéronautique qui
prépare la reprise
et puis également un sujet sur
l'alimentation le pari du local les
circuits courts le point vous donne
évidemment toutes les indications bouclé
mais évidemment bien manger localement à
toulouse c'est donc 36 pages en fin de
journal consacré à toulouse par
l'édition locale du point et puis une
deuxième édition locale l'envoyer sur
votre écran les secrets de nice et c'est
une magnifique une dans l'église
orthodoxe grecque de st cyp rideaux etc
les bons plans pour s'évader à l'heure
du conte vide à nice qui vous sont
racontées par les équipes locales et
nationales du point le point mission
locale qui est dirigée par jérôme
cordelier qui est également le rédacteur
en chef du service politique de ce grand
magazine d'information nous recevons
d'ailleurs dans une prochaine édition du
grand jt des territoires voit la fin de
cette édition jour précisément toutes
bientôt sur vos chaînes de télévision
locales et régionales de la tnt ainsi
que sur tv5 monde
au revoir à tous et à très vite
[Musique]